أجنبية
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى] [موسيقى]
أجنبية [
موسيقى] أجنبية
تفتقر إلى وسائل أجنبية أجنبية أجنبية أجنبية أجنبية [
موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
أجنبية
أجنبية أجنبية
ألبانيا هي دراسة حالة لأوروبا
لأن ألبانيا تنتج 100
متجدد  الطاقة ، لذلك لم يكن لدينا أي
نوع من المشاكل مع الغاز الروسي ، ولكن
من ناحية أخرى ، حتى إنتاج 100
طاقة متجددة ، فإننا معرضون في
السوق الدولية للطاقة لأننا
مضطرون لاستيراد حوالي 20
بالمائة من احتياجات البلاد خلال
2022 الحكومة الألبانية
والشركة التي أنفقت الشركات الوطنية التي
تقدم الطاقة في البلاد
حوالي نصف مليار
يورو فقط لتوفير الطاقة
لمواطننا لأننا اتخذنا قرارًا جريئًا للغاية
لحماية جميع أصحاب المنازل
والصغار  الأعمال التجارية في ألبانيا من
أزمة الطاقة هذه
في الخارج
بشكل جيد ، لدينا هدف قوي للغاية
نريد تحقيقه بحلول عام 2030 لزيادة
طاقتنا الإنتاجية بأربعة تيرابايت
عن طريق تحويل ألبانيا من بلد مستورد صافٍ
إلى بلد مُصدِّر صافٍ كما
قلت في لوحتي  بالنسبة لنا ، من
المهم جدًا إنشاء
مزيج مستدام من الطاقة
التي تنتج فقط من الطاقة المتجددة
تبدو عصرية للغاية ولكن من ناحية أخرى ،
يجب أن يكون لدينا أمن الطاقة
لبلدنا ولهذا
نعمل على مشروع جديد يتضمن
إنتاج  الطاقة من خلال fsru
القائمة على جنوب ألبانيا وعلى أساس
توريد الغاز الطبيعي المسال ، لذلك سيكون هدفنا ممكن
الوصول إليه بالطبع إذا وصلنا إلى هذا
النوع من الإنتاج ،
ما هو مهم للغاية وما
أعتقد أنه سيكون مفتاح النجاح
هو  التآزر بين استثمار
القطاع الحكومي والقطاع الخاص للدولة
والقطاع الخاص فقط لإعطائك
مثالًا بسيطًا خلال عام 2022 من خلال وجود
هذا الوضع في جميع أنحاء أوروبا ، كان لدينا
حوالي
1.7 جيجا بايت من الاستثمار من
القطاع الخاص في الطاقة المتجددة
بالطبع و  كان الحقن على
الاقتصاد يساوي
1.1 مليار يورو لبلد صغير
مثل ألبانيا لأنني أعتقد أنك
تعرف أن ألبانيا بلد صغير
مع ثلاثة ملايين من الأدلة ، وهذا
استثمار مهم للغاية ومن خلال
التنسيق وإنشاء هذا النوع من
التآزر بين القطاعات التي نعتقد
أن هذا الاستثمار سيصل في المستقبل إلى
أكثر من 20 مليار يورو حتى
2230 وهو هدفنا المستهدف أن نكون أغنياء ، إنه
معقد للغاية الآن هذا هو
الوضع ليس مرتبطًا فقط
بأزمة الطاقة لدينا أزمة  التي تأتي
من الطمع ثم بعد ذلك الطمع وكل
شيء كان مرتبطًا بارتفاع
الأسعار بسبب الطلبات الكبيرة
إلى فائض طلب السوق ،
لذلك لا يتعلق الأمر بالمعادن فحسب ، بل
يتعلق بهذا الطلب الرهيب
للسوق للحصول على المزيد من الإنشاءات الكهروضوئية
الحدائق المزيد من إنشاءات الحدائق العولية
بالطبع التي أثرت على الوضع
والقطاع ولكن من ناحية أخرى فإن
الأسعار المطبقة على بيع
الطاقة جذابة للغاية
للشركات حتى تتمكن من موازنة هذا الارتفاع في
أسعار المواد الخام التي
ستكون عام 2023  عام حاسم
فيما يتعلق
دعنا نقول استدامة
القطاع لأنه خلال عام 2022 لا يمكنك
الاعتماد بأي حقيقة على أي أرقام لأنه
كان عامًا مجنونًا للطاقة بالنسبة
لأوروبا ولكل العالم
الأجنبي
[موسيقى]
وابادا أجنبي
أجنبي
هناك بعض الدعم للطلب على الطاقة
نظرًا لأن الصين أسرع في أه
وأسرع إعادة فتحها ، لذلك هناك
قوتان متعارضتان مختلفتان في مكانهما
جيدًا ، من الصعب التحدث عن الفائزين في
سياق الحرب ولكن إذا كان الأمر كذلك إذا
كنا نركز فقط  في مجال الطاقة ،
كانت الولايات المتحدة في صالحها بسبب
ذلك البئر ، أي منتج للطاقة
ليس مفضلًا لروسيا على الأقل بسبب
الأسعار المرتفعة ، لذا فإن
صادرات المطار أكثر قيمة في الوقت الحالي
ولكن من الواضح أن أوروبا تبتعد عن
روسيا والأحفوريات  الوقود وتم تسليط الضوء عليه
للتسرع في العثور على موردين آخرين
رأوه في الولايات المتحدة مثل شريك جيد
في الولايات المتحدة رأوه
كعملاء جيدين في بلدانك الأوروبية ،
كما أن صادراتك الأمريكية تزداد
بشكل كبير لأنها تملأ
الفجوة التي تفرضها روسيا
الخارجية
بشكل جيد الحرب في أوكرانيا
وخاصة أحشاء
إمدادات الوقود الأحفوري الروسي نحو أوروبا أو أه قد
سلطت الضوء على أمن الطاقة
مرة أخرى لذلك كان هناك
إعادة غرض من سياسة الطاقة أو
سياسة الطاقة من انتقال الطاقة
إلى أمن الطاقة  خلال عام 2022
ورأينا العديد من الدول أه في مثل ألمانيا
أو دول أخرى في الاتحاد الأوروبي
تستثمر بكثافة في
البنية التحتية للوقود الأحفوري خاصة في قدرة استيراد الغاز الطبيعي المسال
بسبب قضية أمن الطاقة
لذا أصبح أمن الطاقة الآن تحت
دائرة الضوء على
الجميع في العالم كل يوم
صانع السياسة لأنه وضع مثل أداة
الإنارة وعدم الأمان ليس شيئًا
ممنوحًا لذلك نحن نشهد
جهدًا متجددًا بشأن أمن الطاقة
لا يعني أن البلدان لا
تفكر في انتقال الطاقة
ونؤمن بـ  حقيقة أن
الوضع الحالي سيتسارع هناك باعتباره
انتقالًا على المدى المتوسط ​​والطويل
وخاصة لأن العديد من الحكومات
ترى الآن التجديدات ليس فقط
كوسيلة
للحصول على بيئة أفضل ولكن أيضًا إلى أين
كطريقة لفرض
أمن الطاقة لأنهم "  إعادة
الموارد التلقائية المنتجة محليًا أثناء
عدم الحاجة إلى استيراد
بعضها أو الفوز بالمرح ،
فالبنية التحتية موجودة
وستستمر روسيا في كونها
منتجًا مهمًا للغاز على المدى الطويل
على الرغم من الإنتاج سننخفض والبنية
التحتية موجودة ونحن  هل هذه
ليست توقعاتنا الأساسية ولكن إذا فكرنا
في مثل تغيير منطقة في
روسيا والدول الأوروبية تحاول
دعم هذا النظام الجديد وبالطبع
يمكننا أن نرى أه مثل تصدير المتلقي
من روسيا إلى الولايات المتحدة إلى
الاتحاد الأوروبي  الاستئناف لأن
خطوط الأنابيب موجودة تمامًا ولكننا
لا نتوقع أن يحدث ذلك على
المدى القصير
في الخارج ،
وهناك الكثير من الاستثمار الذي يحتاج إلى
إجابة قصيرة أخرى ونحن
نحترم التجديد مثل المزيد من الاستثمار ،
نعم بالطبع في مصادر الطاقة المتجددة على وجه الخصوص
من الدول الأوروبية ولكن أيضًا
نتوقع مزيدًا من الاستثمار في إنتاج الوقود الأحفوري
وهذا أه ليس فقط لأنه أه أم
لأنه هناك حاجة
لموازنة الطلب على العرض ولكن أيضًا
لأن الأسعار على الأقل
مرتفعة في الوقت الحالي حتى  على الرغم من أنها
انخفضت من ارتفاعات 2022 ، إلا أنها
تظل مرتفعة ويتم
دفع الأسعار المرتفعة دائمًا لمزيد من
الاستثمار في الوقود الأحفوري ، نتوقع أن
يستمر سوق النفط والغاز قصيرًا أو
مستمرًا للغاية من ضيق جدًا من على
الأقل حتى عام 2025 وذلك  بالطبع سوف
ندعم الاستثمار في
إعادة إنتاج الوقود الأحفوري
الذي
نراه مثل السوق العالمي
مثل الانقسام في معسكرين أحدهما
سيستمر في تلقي
الواردات الروسية أه كما نستمر في
الاستيراد من روسيا
وسأزيد من  الاستيراد من
روسيا هذا هو بشكل أساسي الصين والهند
لأنهم سيحصلون على
أسعار إيجابية رخيصة جدًا منهم ومن ثم
البلدان الأخرى التي تبتعد عن
روسيا وستركز أكثر على
الولايات المتحدة
كمورد عالمي وهذا
يشبه بشكل أساسي  لن أصفها بأنها
تنافس بين
هذين المعسكرين ، بالطبع ، إنه
صراع بين روسيا والاتحاد الأوروبي
وبيننا ، لكنني لن أسميها
مثل النهر بين أوروبا والصين ،
لكن هذا هم  سأعني تمامًا أن
الصين ستفعل ما هو أفضل من
أجل الشؤون المالية أو سأحاول الحصول على
وقود أحفوري رخيص من روسيا بينما
سيكون على أوروبا أن تتمكن من
اقتصادها بشكل أسرع تمامًا مثل محاولة
الابتعاد عن Securus بشكل عام
والاعتماد أكثر في الولايات المتحدة كمورد للطاقة ،
لا يمكنك الاعتماد على مورد واحد
لمعظم واردات الوقود الأحفوري ،
وهذا مهم للغاية
لأنه درس
تتعلمه الصين وتلعب الكثير من الاهتمام كما
ترى الصين  بالطبع تحاول
الحصول على المزيد من الغاز على النفط من روسيا ولكن
كل روسيا والصين الأخرى تحاول أيضًا
تنويع إمداداتها مما
يجعل المزيد من الاستثمار في آسيا الوسطى
هناك مثل خط أنابيب جديد تم الإعلان عنه
مع تورميرستان ولذا نعتقد أن
هذا
سيجعل  تكون الحكومات أكثر وعيًا بمخاطر
الاعتماد المفرط في
مورد طاقة واحد ، وسوف أه
درس آخر سيكون محاولة إنتاج
المزيد محليًا وأنا لا أتحدث
عن النفط والغاز ، لذا فأنا أتحدث فقط
عن ذلك الأكثر متجددًا  لذلك سنرى
الآن التجديدات يتم اعتبارها وسيلة
لتعزيز أه أمن الطاقة
والدرس الثالث هو أهمية كفاءة الطاقة
في العديد من الدول الأوروبية التي لم
تكن طموحة للغاية بشأن كفاءة الطاقة
وما شابه ذلك في السنوات العشر الماضية و  نشهد الآن
عواقب الحياة عندما
تحتاج إلى تقليل الاستهلاك لأنك
لا تملك المورد لأن
الأسعار باهظة الثمن
ويواجهون بعض الصعوبات
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
شكرًا لك [
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك